bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono felice oggi stiamo
sul gioco che avete chiesto praticamente
tutti sono molto spaventato da questo
perché in genere i giochi che sono
supergiocate non è detto che siano belli
ma voglio essere fiducioso si chiama
poppi playtime io non ho visto niente
non sa di cosa stiamo parlando giuro non
ho visto ancora nulla ed è importante
che non abbia visto che almeno tutta una
potuto sorpresa questo e poppi che dal
nome non è che mi faccia paura però so
già che sto per pentirmi di questa fase
di merda che ho appena detto chapter one
attenti squeeze credo sia simile a fi
nate freddy's non lo so comunque è uno
di quei mood lì quindi di un impatto sui
video di eminem questa è la prima
bambola che in grado di fare di fare
conversazione con un bambino
cioè quindi hanno iniziato a vendere
queste bambole che ha fatto in versano
quindi ricapitolando hanno venduto ste
bambole che parlano i bambini poppi
plate puoi andare a visitare la factory
minchia come c'ho voglia andiamo subito
eccoci buongiorno credo che si abbiano
chiuso ovviamente visto la faccenda
hanno chiuso è rimasta abbandonata la
fetta di perché sono scomparsi tutti gli
impiegati
va bene pure è benvenuto incredibile
allora ragazzi non aver avete idea di
che cosa stiamo parlando però comunque
se questa fare continua a girare a 10
anni è un po lo spreco di energia fatelo
dire c'è un filenet freddy's qua più
meno non so bene poppi world su play sì
sì anche emily diciamo così poi però
mi scusi non volevo questa roba a in
codice va bene con la fico ad ottica a
il pavimento guardate bianco manca poco
proprio lui che vede le cose e le
azzecca ragazzi ma non è che il trenino
rosso giallo rosa e poi cose verde
vediamo al tipo è rosso giallo rosa e
verde
bellissimo era molto semplice in realtà
per ora ho un neurone che balla la samba
io non è che potete pretendere tac età
sono anche cosa ho fatto play time inc
graham cutts estero a titolo fichi
addosso e inizia a prendere le cose
bellissimo questo è mio e lo prendo
me lo metto aspetta subito eccolo qua
posso firelight and porca [ __ ]
nick è fortissimo
ma è fatto bene ma geniale cioè un altro
braccio al collo perché non solo uno a
26 frega ti do un 5
star ove geniale bellissimo
grazie e non ho capito niente dicono
arrivederci
beh comunque gentile almeno quello
dobbiamo sempre ricordarci comunque che
è sparito il personale di questo foto
fini non facciamo proprio quelli i
minchioni perché non ha senso lo sta
diventando un po krypi la faccenda
proprio alto voltaggio darà finché lo
tocco costo braccio era ok
ok
io le braccia normali non ce l'ho più
c'è solo questo praticamente va bene
alto voltaggio ma che usa cosa devo fare
con questo touch su white power a lo
porto qua
no vabbè weight fighissimo a posso
allungare il braccio fino a un certo
punto è e geniale questa cosa ragazzi
veramente
e dove minchia me lo porto nel menu
mettono in coppa e fa il fiocco fa il
fiocco
beh
ho dato energia tu
mi scusi ma come ha fatto a sparire
michele è un gigante di attacco ntà il
cancro è andato via
anche se ho capito che ti chiami
abbraccio zoe in italiano dovrebbero
traduco le sono la soul inglese ora ora
posso passare senza che mi salta in
faccia nessuno bene
arrivederci mi servirebbe anche l'altro
bra
e no mi scusi c'è un pointer non puoi
essere tratto qua dentro e di enorme
e le popolari cuoio
all'inferno stairway to hell mi sembra
un po eccessivo però andiamo avanti
aggie
aghi bello porca [ __ ]
ti di un secchiello per farla riva no no
non ho ben capito
perché dovresti avercela con me e non ho
fatto niente ma mica sono del personale
io qua io sono venuto qua quella
visitatore ho pagato il biglietto
tripadvisor c'è qua e ti faccio rating
una stella poi un casino devo fare qua
ho bisogno di una casseruola davanti a
cassette io non capisco niente di quello
che mi dicono prova davanti a cassette
cordati di prendere i freni che casulli
esce un'altra roba da fare con il
cervello no e io non lo so usare molto
bene invece della roba 1 i boss e poi
non so dove sia
perché uno l'ho già preso questi cosa
gli altri due ma anche il quarto ragazzi
e non solo e si sa però se
ci ho messo due ora trovarlo ma fa
niente e ora devo mettere tutti i pezzi
qua giusto non so come ecco le più free
air four è tutto veramente molto strano
perché non ho capito dove dobbiamo
andare a parare questa faccenda io video
tra gli impiegati che hanno carica hanno
rubato gli impregni impiegati non ho
capito grazie a questa è l'altra mano
teoricamente no grazie di avermelo
scalzata per terra
gentile e la prendo con la loro mano per
mano
perfetto ora sì che sono felice non so
bene cosa faccio così 12
del giardino 21 temperley o entro il
presidente fosse va bene è una figata
come concept solo che non ho capito dove
sto finendo va bene ma pensavo ci fosse
il jump scarico meno male non c'è stato
non c'è stato il jump square arrivederci
8 chili di giocattoli inutili
praticamente prova bene
knicks power e allora niente io sono
parigine sbagliato da presso quella è la
cosa veramente più critica il piano
quando l'hanno fatto non hanno visto ma
cosa che crei visto posto magari non lo
facciamo
ma perché un visitatore di norma doveva
fare cose mi sono un po eccessivo ma ce
l'ho fatta
ma sono un emerito pirla bastava fare
questo ma è una cagata è una cagata sono
stupido che è successo
ho dato il power mi butto e mi uccido
come si fa
iolo
io io io mi tengo alle cose facendo
finta di avere un rampino poi non so
che cazzo vuoi da me è a [ __ ] a soldi
ho detto la parola con l'aci però si può
dire se giampiero bipa non è che ti di
incazzare questi non sanno come funziona
monetizzazione prova bene adesso ragazzi
vi spiego come si creano incubi fi gelo
spiega allora prendi pezzi di bambole
gli attacchi a caso
lo metti davanti alla sedia che sta
vicino alla letto che la notte dormi
guardi la sedia se si muove hai fatto
bene il tuo lavoro che bello un'altra
donna come lo volevo in casa questo
affare che prima non ce l'avevo posso
prenderlo no no non andargli armellini
qua
a posto ce l'ho l'ho preso e guarda
nella vita reale cielo simile non è
proprio lo stesso però qualche lui mi
fissa mentre dorme tutto tutto sempre
molto bello anzi wire metto qua molto
bene a eccolo mentre qua
potete scannerizzare il diritto cioè una
tessera magnetica
va bene ragazzi va bene non benissimo
questo porca [ __ ] tua madre
mannaggia chi t'ha fatto dovevamo aiuto
e si è aperta con la guarderemo anche a
tropea che moltissimi giovani
minchia è uscito fuori un coso grosso va
bene
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no per favore ve lo
chiedo perché stai
devi stare fermo esposta nei condotti
case a yen porca put non fu sorella in
alitalia
addio benedetto dino
mi diceva che non ci credo ma è un ritmo
e orribile henry me è un gioco orribile
mi chiede generata la situa dai cori
nome male pazzesco
cioè non ho mai visto una cosa del
genere in un gioco horror ma che cazzo
fai quanto fatto bene servizio pazzesca
e vabbè dove cazzola lei quale nemico
apre la porta
oddio sapete
noi ragazze non so cosa dire non so cosa
dire cuore li porco demonio coree
oddio 78 storia basata
a posto a posto nostro cazzo sta
sfondando
addio
6 sfondate tutto madonna l'ho preso l'ho
ucciso no è incredibile che sono
fenomeno sono fortissimo sono
incredibile sono veramente ehi guarda
qua minchia suo muscolo madonna come ti
tiro staff agli hotel a un leader ok ho
perso un polmone il fegato e forse anche
un po il coccige devo capito a posto
posso la posta grazie del consiglio
ragazzi veramente non so many casa
eccolo il fiore a questo è il fiore
quello di ricevano gli impiegati
dicevano vai segui il fiore questo siamo
arrivati non so come vedi che si sono
rifugiati tutti qua dentro scommetto che
vivono da dieci anni li segregati perché
non possono uscire no run non so
comunque ragazzi tra parentesi
l'inseguimento più bello degli ultimi
anni in un organo cioè fatto veramente
da paura sbaglia se in un film l'ha
fatto che mi giocavo veramente io
spettacolo fatto benissimo complimenti
cosa c'è scritto danger tonara un no
stop go back
credo che queste queste queste siano
insegne per il tizio non tanto per me
cioè della serie forse per tenerlo
lontano scriviamo queste cose e magari
essendo un giocattolo si
è cambiata l'ambiente totalmente diversa
coi muri demi nomina tra l'altro
bellissimo
ragazzi c'è qualcuno qua sto cercando
gli impiegati che sono spariti da dieci
anni e forse c'è un motivo
effettivamente
poppy queste poppi
no no
arrivederci
sì sì sì quello che stai dicendo mi
interessa
stava andando via io no è finito è
finito così cosa no ma comincia la corsa
è già finito dorato niente ma no ma dai
carc questa la chat per juan marca il
chapter ii da fare che non è ancora
uscito il secondo esce va bene una cosa
pensa allora il genere quando gli horror
fanno successo
non è detto che siano belli anzi con la
quale successi genere perché non sono
belli per qualche tipo granny a me fa
schifo grandi non so perché abbiamo
giusto successo però va bene quindi mi
aspettavo più o meno la stessa che
invece nota più queste fatto proprio
bene però sento ragazzi servita piaciuto
a cielo aperto e o vi piace anche ai
social come notate nella descrizione se
non c'è da questi iscrivetevi e io e
freddi vi salutiamo
che videro cieche che bello giocare
l'horror da dieci anni ho già 80 anni
dentro a voi non lo sapete bene ragazzi
[Musica]